you can also join the discussion with
more than uh close to 35 000 actually of
our viewers and listeners on the david
pakman show subreddit that's at
davidpakman.com
reddit
r-e-d-d-i-t
let's look at a few posts from the
subreddit first one from user joey death
says does ukraine realize that a no-fly
zone equals world war iii there's really
no way to word this without throwing
shade at the ukrainians but i keep
hearing ukraine and the zielinski
administration calling for a no-fly zone
as i'm sure many of you have as well
there's obviously no happy ending in
store for ukraine but i do wonder if
this is a heat of the moment thing for
them since the no-fly zone and other u.s
nato restrictions can lead to world war
three am i just not seeing it from their
heated perspective so
it it
it is both true that a no-fly zone could
well be the trigger for world war three
but you also are not seeing it from the
ukrainian perspective so let's think
think through that
why would a no-fly zone potentially mean
world war three well the the issue with
the no-fly zone is
announcing a no-fly zone
is just an announcement it doesn't
necessarily mean anything
but when you
announce a no-fly zone
you have to enforce the no-fly zone and
what that means is
shooting down planes if they violate the
no-fly zone and it leaves open
the idea that russia could
just violate the no-fly zone with with
um uh pilot pipe human pilot piloted
planes
um or send drones to have them
deliberately shot down to then justify
an escalation there's all sorts of
different ways in which the enforcement
of the no-fly zone could indeed lead to
world war three what you also have to
consider as many of our reddit users
uh made clear
um
from the perspective of the ukrainians
they are seeing total war from russia
and they recognize that even if they've
been able to resist certain advancements
from russia to some degree russia's
military is absolutely massive and so
although the enforcement of the no-fly
zone
could lead to some deaths
my guess is
the ukrainian calculation is it'll save
a ton of people in in other words you
shoot down a plane and it lands and the
plane crashing kills a few people but
think about how many ukrainians could be
killed if that plane is able to do
bombing sorties sorties in ukraine so i
i think that we we aren't seeing it from
the ukrainian perspective
and there's also accuracy accuracy to
the no-fly zone enforcement could be
world war iii as of right now
no no-fly zone has been put in place
user hohh
posted to the subreddit is sexism
unavoidable what if a female comedian
delivered the baldness joke at the
oscars would will smith has had slapped
her and then walked away to receive a
standing ovation within minutes yeah i
think this is a fair point
um
and i think that uh it is
inevitable
that the situation was seen the way it
was seen
to some degree because the joke was made
about a woman's hair
and the person telling the joke was male
and the person doing the slapping was
also male now i don't know that it's
sexism necessarily but i think that this
post correctly identifies
that were it you know whitney cummings
or nikki glazer or whoever whatever
female comedian telling that joke about
jada pinkett smith
if will smith goes up and slaps her the
way he slapped chris rock
um
he's certainly kicked out i mean i guess
they tried to kick him out and will
smith just stayed and nobody did
anything about it he's certainly kicked
out if not arrested i think that's true
i think also there's another aspect to
this which is if the joke had been made
about
a bald man
likely never would have been a slap
anyway i mean i think there's no way to
to remove gender dynamics from that
situation
that doesn't necessarily make it sexism
and everything that that connotes but
there's no question that gender played a
role in everybody's reaction
um
last post today from early gold who
posted please support the bonus show
so we can get better audio controls yeah
i'm gonna play for you there have been
some horrible audio issues plaguing the
live streams lately here's just a little
bit of a of of a reminder for those who
might have hearing myself coming back
that's weird
are you guys hearing me twice every time
you're not
just wait for it okay let's try now
okay okay let's try now no i still
didn't i'm still hearing myself okay
okay let's try now no i still didn't i'm
still hearing myself okay okay let's try
now no i still didn't i'm still killing
myself okay okay let's try now no i
still didn't i'm still hearing myself
okay okay let's try now no i still
didn't i'm still hearing myself okay
let's try it out now i still didn't know
anyway i won't plague you guys with the
entire thing but that did go on for
about 10 minutes it's not we don't need
a donation to fix that or anything some
people thought david you know maybe we
need to donate to fix your audio no it
was just a user error that's all it was
but i think we very very soon are going
to have the audio figured out for the
live streams join the discussion on the
subreddit at davidpakman.com
reddit